&gt;&gt; Oh, so Andy, it sounds like our senseletes are getting ready for the final
events. Let's go back to Susan and see what's going on. Back to you, Susan.
&gt;&gt; Hi, you guys. It's really exciting over here. As you can see, we're getting set
up with the eye charts, and the athletes are warming up for the first sight
event.
&gt;&gt; And how does this event work?
&gt;&gt; Well, actually you can see the charts have letters with different sizes on
them.
&gt;&gt; The contestants have to read the letters, and those that can read the smallest
letters get more points awarded. They have to read those without glasses.
&gt;&gt; Any comments from what you've seen so far in this event?
&gt;&gt; It's actually pretty interesting how dramatically different some of our
contestants are. For example, some cannot even read the largest letters, where
some can read almost all of the smallest ones.
&gt;&gt; Yeah, it looks like some of our contestants are nearsighted huh, Susan?
&gt;&gt; You're definitely right Andy. It's a good thing these contestants can wear
their glasses when they're not at these events.
&gt;&gt; Lucky indeed. Thanks a lot Susan.